hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen today I
am watching Howl's Moving Castle I went
into this knowing that I was going to
enjoy it at least the tone the style of
it I have seen spirited away and Kiki
they're like anime lights and they're
like the Disney of anime these are films
that I always get recommended to watch
for it's always like watch Howl's Moving
Castle watch princess mo Mona Mona Mona
no chemo no key it's also so unique and
original usually for these at least
lately I've been trying to kind of dress
up for them in some kind of way and for
this one I didn't know a character to
dress as or like even give it like a
slight nod to so I'm literally wearing a
Star Wars Star Wars dress because I
don't know let's get into this I can't
wait to talk about it
[Music]
you
I loved it the detail of the backdrops
and the backgrounds that you get versus
the simplicity honestly of the
characters that you see like right in
front of you there's just like I'm also
the food oh I want to eat everything
that's on screen I haven't eaten in all
day
I can't wait can't mess up the lipstick
you know I have the story was really
cool really weird the biggest thing I
took from it was the piece that our lead
character got when she was turned into
an old woman some of the lines she says
as an old woman we're just so beautiful
and I was talking to my friend about
this that like I have a fear of of
growing old and this almost kind of
remedied that like to a certain extent
compared to watching Top Gun laughs to
me this was just a breath of fresh air
in the writing Department though I will
say there are a few questions I still
have maybe it just takes rewatching
there's not much consistency in why she
is an old woman and she is because of
this spell but she like goes in and out
of being an old woman and a young girl a
lot throughout the film and there's not
really a consistent answer for why you
can say that maybe it's her least
stressed moments that she like turns
back into a girl or like if she's not
thinking about it our main character is
named Sophie and she doesn't think of
herself as a beautiful person and she
thinks she's pretty plain and she runs
this gorgeous hot shop that I just adore
and she's walking down the street and
these two guards come after her and
start hitting on her heavily in a gross
way one of them literally says I like
her better when she's scared and that's
and then how this shows up and helps her
and he's got an amazing cape and
incredible hair and jewelry and powers
and I'm I guess more of how as much howl
as we can get she's kind of warns that
if you are hanging out with like a
wizard or a witch they can steal your
heart
or you can get a spell on you end and
it's again not a good things to be
careful be careful and she's just like I
mean it was sick ma'am she's closing
down the hat shop and she's alone and
this woman comes in this Wicked Witch
comes in and curses her because she
loves how and also want something from
how so she curses Sophie our main
character and turns Sophie into an old
woman and it's terrifying can you
imagine that one moment you're your age
in the next moment you're like 60 years
older I can't imagine that she's like I
feel like it hit me with these bells
please but then she just accepts it
she's like you know she takes a moment
to be like well that's craisins that's
nuts
and then she's like all right well I
guess I'll just make the best of it good
day everyone goodbye mother goodbye
forever just leaves so she's going out
and she's looking for a witch or a
wizard who can reverse this spell and
she runs into a scarecrow who has been
cursed and he is so adorable yet creepy
he's my favorite a story arc and the
whole thing I loved everyone's but I he
was just so endearing and sweet and such
a lovely kind friend but he's creepy as
hell like he's like this lifeless thing
and his fingers are like creepy in my
head I've been scratching while my
thoughts are busy of hatching if I only
had a brain
oh uh okay I'm sorry then she jumps on
house-moving gasp you see this
beautifully designed giant alive moving
castle and it's incredibly detailed and
terrifying and awesome and II totally
want to get on it and the design of
everything in this film is great but
obviously they needed to make Howl's
Moving Castle castle that Luce and his
house very impressive and they did an
amazing quote she says one good thing
about getting old is nothing makes you
frightened
that is the good thing about getting
gold I should have seen a lion song
about courage I can't do a line then you
meet the fire character Billy Crystal
plays this fire PETA from Hunger Games
plays the little boy character who I
also just adore I just the whole group
of howl and PETA I'm just gonna call
them P X I forgot his name
I don't know anyone's names the fire and
then Sophie it's just such a good
grouping and eventually you even get the
witch and this dog and it's just it's
really lovely and well-balanced so part
of the curse that was put on her is that
she can't talk about the curse that's
put on her so she's here to get it
reversed but she can't talk about it so
until she can figure out a way to
reverse it she is going to pose as the
cleaner on Howl's Moving Castle howl has
some incredible quotes my favorite is I
don't see the point of living if I can't
be beautiful and then right after that
soap he's like I've never been viewable
in my whole life
and they're both honestly they're both
so relatable then howl says I can't
stand how scared I am through the quotes
are just so sweet like yeah thank you
for saying these things out loud to
children they need to hear this also
adults so at this point how is very
scared there's a lot of war going on but
he also isn't like 'fuck hear how that
they all need Sophie is Sophie is like
by far the hero of this story I love the
kind of struggle with Hal where he's
like this scared guy and he's kind of
fighting his own demons
and he's turning into a bird monster and
is he heroic or is he a selfish man
child and he is he's becoming heroic
because of Sophie and she's helping him
so much and he's falling in love with
her and she's falling in love with him I
wrote Sophie has a Rosemary's Baby hair
moment and we love it this is an
impossible movie to explain but the
witch Steel's house heart like a selfish
bitch it's what I wrote in the heat of
the moment Sophie says I just can't seem
to stop crying
relatable the war's over house heart is
retrieved turnip head is turned back
into a human cuz he was cursed and he
says that he's in love with Sophie and
she's like sorry man but I'm in love a
pal he's like it's okay it's cool I'll
just stop the war now he's a prince of
some shit amazing oh my god this is my
fav studio ghibli movie I'm so excited
you're doing this prediction you will
fall in love with the art how could you
not and want to watch every Studio
Ghibli movie ever made which is a good
idea also house a drama queen yes yes
yes yes how is a drama queen I do want
to watch them all and the style and just
absolute complete artistry of this film
is just stunning and again I said this
elaborate it's weird
Rama sophie is the best honestly is some
of her quotes truly like dug deep in my
heart and helps me as a person with like
coping with getting such an incredible
movie you'll love the Sophie doesn't
behave like a damsel even as things get
weirder and weirder I do I also don't
usually love the trope of like I've
never been beautiful when you're clearly
beautiful but you really get the sense
that she does not think that she's
pretty at all and that she's cool with
that she's like yeah I'm just a plain
Jane that's cool I have other things
like I am sassy as hell and so great and
I love that I love you that because all
of your work doesn't come from being
beautiful so that you've accepted that
it's just so nice and even when she's
like at 80 years old she's like yeah
cool whatever let me just like get this
job real quick cleaning this Sorcerer's
house and then
you know fall in love with him it's
awesome you'll be confused by the
inconsistency in Sophie's curse
throughout the movie yes that's the only
thing I have with this film that I feel
like could have been remedied with just
like a little bit of story where they
give so much story to so much so much
ounce just tell me why why why but that
is also kind of cool because I had a
really nice conversation about it
afterwards like why do you think this is
and I really enjoyed that too
thank you so much for watching next week
I do watching
Braveheart for the first time I'll see
you guys then
that's just life man
[Music]
[Applause]
you